all right welcome today we're going to
make a some sort of like indie folk some
sort of Dylan Gosset cassette Dyan
Gosset type of thing uh just like that
country folk stuff that's popular
nowadays like that Zack Bryan stuff so
I'm not going to be recording acoustic
guitar in this video I actually already
recorded it here it is in the session
but if you want to know it was recorded
with an old BC Rich acoustic guitar it's
not even a good sounding guitar um I use
an at4040 uh right off the bridge and a
l 040 pointing at the 12 fret so that's
it uh we recorded three parts I recorded
an intro which sounds like this
[Music]
and then I move the mic slightly to get
a bit of a tighter feel um I I pretty
much just moved them a little more
together and made sure the phas is all
correct to get the the main guitar uh
which leads a little more space for the
[Music]
vocals and the left channel is turned
down about 7 DB just cuz I want it to
feel a little more to the right what
I've been doing a lot recently is
panning stuff you know left instead of
left right and Center um I'll pan it
like slightly off and not really have
too wide of a thing cuz I want to have
contrast and if you have everything in
the width and everything in the mono
then there's not really too much
contrast and there's not really much
positioning so uh for this main track I
just have a left and right but the left
is turned down so really the guitar sits
right here if I turn the left track up
it sits in the middle because it's so
tight it's going to sit like right here
in your face right here in your face and
if I want the vocal to be there too it's
going to collide if the vocal is here
and the guitar is here it's kind of hard
so right now I have the guitar right
here and the the vocal will go around
here a little more off to the left and
the last track we have is a double which
is just the exact same mic technique the
exact same positioning just the same
just a different
part let check this phase ailon 12's got
this beautiful new feature that has
never been seen before in any da ever
and it's to make the waveforms bigger
I'm just kidding it's in every other da
Ableton was just very late to the party
and so that all sounds like
this
[Music]
it's a pretty simple guitar sound um
there's not a ton of body in it and I
think it does a good job of mimicking
the Dy and Gosset sound lastly we have a
bass uh the Basse was just completely
died it was recorded with a a jazz bass
it's like a jazz basses base it's uh
it's a custommade made Jazz base but
we'll just say it's a jazz base for now
and it just sounds like
this so standard standard base you can
even use Mo Moto base like a a VST base
those things do work I promise you uh I
used to think they didn't but they do if
you know how to use them that's the
track we've got so far I'm going to add
a couple more things and we're going to
start mixing one thing I always add is a
roomy electric guitar I'm going to pick
up a strat and I'm going to go into I
think I'm going to go into amplitube
just cuz amplitube has a nice roomy raw
sort of feel uh not really polished so
we're going to try that out and actually
now that I think about it if you guys
are interested in the the way I recorded
all this stuff there's a there's an
Instagram live on my Instagram if you
guys wanted to watch it's not really the
most entertaining thing but you know if
you wanted to see how I recorded it it's
right there I think I'm just going to do
that I'm going to use the SRV clean in
Solo looks like it's just a tube clean
with
some just a compressor and some EQ and
two cabs I mean cool and actually I want
to add some more room in there not
to yeah I'm going to add some more room
in there just going to increase
that now it sounds like it's recorded in
a real room so think for this first
course uh I'm going to keep it a little
more mellow and on the last course so go
a little heavier uh so what I'm going to
do right now is just a like a lead line
like a
[Music]
something like
that
uh now you'll notice that is in the
middle if you're using
headphones so I'm just going to pan
[Music]
it check this compression I'm going to
throw proed 2 behind the amp because I
want to compress the signal going into
[Music]
it
there we go and then I'll I'll thr that
uh oh I thought we had a Reverb on here
S A Reverb on there um just like a plate
I'm sure it's
fine
um let's do a
delay all right let's go back into AML
tube now I want to do a sort of like a
supporting section with the guitar uh so
for this I'll
use I don't know a tube clean two I
guess they sounded good that's fine yeah
uh for this I want something a little
bit
smoother um the 420 On's are really nice
and the r 121s are really nice cuz
they're
ribbons let's hop into
here there we go uh and yeah instead of
a 57 I'm going to go to a
[Music]
421 and then I'm going to increase the
room a little more
[Music]
too there a really crazy uh
resonant resonant tone
here it's that
[Music]
one I'm going to hop into THU slate now
and I want to add one more guitar I
don't know really what I want to add but
I feel like I just need another guitar
Texas Blu single coil probably going to
be a good
[Music]
idea that'll be nice with a room verb on
it see what we've got so
far
just a regular verb
[Music]
ni
you know I really don't like that high
Rhythm I take it back I deleted it um
just cuts through a lot I just don't
think it fits the part um I'll probably
have to add something like it back in
this section in this course um but for
now you know trial and error you do
stuff sometimes it doesn't work so e
guitar rhythm and I'm going to put it on
the second chorus as
[Music]
well
so more guitar I've got this uh
Californian clean delay I haven't tried
it
[Music]
yet I think that sounds pretty
good
all right next we going to try this PT
uh sir PT I guess is what it's
called it's a bit crazy um but they do
have these great little effects racks
that change like impulse
[Music]
responses that sounds good I'm going to
throw a yellow drive on it before
[Music]
that
all right next I'm going to work quickly
on These acoustic guitars okay so I'm
going to group these two guitar layers
because they're basically the same thing
the same part they're just miked a
little differently um and I'm going to
just call this guitar
sub guitar main sub and I'm going to
process them the same so I'm going to
put a bus compressor on there the
townhouse bus compressor I don't know
why I just really really love it and
what I'm shooting for here is just
evening out the guitar so I'm going to
go for a somewhat fast attack um haven't
decided on the release yet but you see
when it's jumping it jumps when there's
like
a so I'm just trying to tame
[Music]
those
yeah throw the vssm 3 on there now just
for some saturation all right listening
to it
off and
on now I want to car out some space for
vocals um just in case anyone wants to
record on this
[Music]
so when the guitar is hitting harder
around the core section we do have a lot
of uh game reduction going
on so I'm going to keep it on a 2 to1
[Music]
ratio
now I'm going to quickly go into the
electric
guitar EQ some of that stuff out on the
entire sub uh I'm going to cut a bit of
lows
I'm going to do some midside stuff uh
I'm going to cut the mids around here
just for some vocal
space yeah so as opposed to
this which would collab with the
vocals this add space of the
vocals cool uh I want some saturation on
there I'm going to to I'm going to
actually try the new what's it called
it's called the verb machines yeah it's
a new uad plugin I I do like it um I
don't really like that it's kind of just
like a uh put this on your mix and its
magic sort of thing like I want to know
what I want more parameters and I want
to know how it works and whatever it
does sound
[Music]
good I'm going to put a fairly clean
compressor on here uh what am I looking
for the Focus right red where is it red
three compressor it's a clean VCA style
uh
[Music]
compressor just to even stuff
out
yeah something like
that let's see what else we can add here
um I I don't like you can hear the the
strings buzzing on the the neck my
guitar is super super low action uh so I
want to try and get rid of
that um and what we could do for that is
just a bit of
overdrive something really
really not crazy the overs scream I'm
not sure if we can get it low gain or
low gain enough low Drive enough oh
actually we have a drive here cool let's
turn that off turn that
[Music]
on that's
better
[Music]
cool all right now lastly for the bass
uh I'm going to throw on an sv3 Pro um
let's
listen they got some nice effect tracks
too what do they
got 49 with a ribbon 421 with a
ribbon yeah that's
nice I'm going to cut out some uh some
of the second harmonic actually yeah
around
there and then the scoop here uh I'm
going to throw a decapitator on
[Music]
there there it
is cool and then a bit of space uh is
all we need to make it fit right in the
mix I know I've been soloing this whole
time and you know you don't want a solo
mix to a
solo but uh trust the
process yeah all right now we'll take
Sol off and we'll
[Music]
mix
La 2 a tube just to even out the signal
going to try and shoot for 3 to 5
[Music]
DB lastly you're going to check in
mono
and actually big in a base model too uh
[Music]
yeah what I do is I'll check in mono and
I'll go to the most complicated like
complex section of the mix with the
mostal layers or whatever and see what's
competing with what and see what I can
do to remedy
[Music]
it
all right let's add some
[Music]
Reverb and that's the beat I hope you
enjoyed um hope you learned something um
if you want these kind of electric
guitar
layers I mean not those exact ones but I
do have a lot of electric guitar layers
I like to layer in with my beads to make
them more threedimensional make them
more filled out if you want to look at
those there's a Shop link down in the
description I think there's like eight
or 10 of them I can't remember but I use
them a lot of time in all my Beats if
you want to use them check them out uh
they really make you
mixes feel more filled out so if you
want to check those out go for it's in
the description anyway bye